bBruit d'oiseaux)
- C'est avec le chant
des oiseaux que Ian et Régina
entament leur journée de
travail. Premier arrêt,
l'entrepôt pour récupérer
les remorques.
Une fois accrochée au vélo,
une remorque peut contenir
jusqu'à 300 livres de matériel.
Ils y mettent des outils,
des pierres d'ardoise, tout pour
concevoir des plates-bandes.
- On va construire un sentier.
- Petite entreprise locale,
Les Jardiniers à bicyclette
existe depuis 13 ans. Ils font
tout à vélo. Une fois les outils
de base à bord...
- Ok!
- Deuxième arrêt : Centre
de location d'outils.
C'est un immense escabeau
de 16 pieds que Ian trimbalera
dans les rues de Montréal.
Tout est bien en selle.
Troisième arrêt : Outremont.
RÉGINA REICHHERZER, jardinière,
Les jardiniers en bicyclette
- On est pas une grosse
compagnie de paysagement,
on est quelques employés,
on a vraiment un lien direct
avec les clients. Souvent,
on devient même ami avec eux.
(rires)
Puis on fait affaire avec
des pépinières sur l'île
de Montréal, comme
nos fournisseurs, pour venir
livrer s'il y a une grosse
cargaison de terre.
- L'opération sera importante
aujourd'hui. Les jardiniers vont
défricher tout le parterre.
- Nous, dans le fond, tout ce
qu'on fait c'est à bras, avec
la force de notre jus de bras
puis on n'utilise pas d'outils
à gaz.
- Régina manie donc une scie
électrique pour faire place
au soleil dans ce jardin.
L'entreprise écoresponsable
oeuvre principalement dans
les quartiers centraux de
Montréal ainsi qu'à Longueuil.
- C'est juste que je ne peux pas
le faire.
- Maria a fait appel à eux pour
l'aider, mais surtout en raison
des valeurs de l'entreprise.
MARIA ARRIETA, cliente
- Il paie très bien
ses travailleurs, donc c'est
possiblement un peu plus cher,
mais je crois qu'il respecte
ses travailleurs comme
il respecte l'environnement.
IAN CHRISTOPHER GOODMAN,
Fondateur Les Jardiniers à bicy.
- Notre entreprise a des prix
semblables à des grosses
entreprises aussi et ce qui est
intéressant, on emploie
les humains, les jardiniers.
Par exemple, pendant
une journée, il y aura cinq
jardiniers, mais avec une grosse
compagnie, peut-être juste
une machine avec un travailleur,
donc c'est cinq jardiniers qui
gagnent de l'argent.
- Des jardiniers qui sont aussi
des conseillers. Au même moment
à Rosemont, Sanda, reçoit
des services personnalisés.
SANDRA HUYNH, cliente
- J'avais envie de me sentir en
Italie dans mon jardin à défaut
de pouvoir voyager.
- Elle fera elle-même
son jardin.
- Elle me place les plantes puis
elle me montre un peu où
les mettre puis elle m'explique
un peu les différents niveaux,
les différents types de
floraison et tout. Puis après
ça, c'est moi qui va exécuter.
- À Outremont, sur le terrain
de Maria, le travail est loin
d'être terminé.
- On essaie de planter
des plantes indigènes,
des plantes comestibles,
des plantes qui ont une utilité.
- Trois jours plus tard, après
le travail de cinq jardiniers
et zéro gaz à effet de serre,
le jardin de Maria est devenu
réalité. Un des projets les plus
ambitieux de la petite compagnie
dont Ian est très fier.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-
Comeau, Radio-Canada, Montréal.